it's generally assumed that when someone
is hung they died by having their neck
broken the official terminology for such
a death is called the hangman's fracture
at the end of the drop the second
cervical vertebra or c2 was fractured by
the weight of the body and the
tightening of the knot this fracture
separates the c2 vertebra from the c3
vertebra causing the spinal cord to snap
in the process resulting in instant
death death by the hangman's fracture is
a quick and humane way to die from
hanging and in a perfect world it would
work every time
unfortunately death by the hangman's
fracture was fairly uncommon in most
hangings in a study published in
forensic science international autopsies
were performed on 34 individuals who
were executed by hanging
of the 34 only three died from the
hangman's fracture while the remaining
31 were not so lucky
if you're looking for a humane way to
die hanging is not one of them there is
multiple variables that determine a
quick clean death and most of them are
not in your favor it's the early 19th
century at such-and-such time in place
you allegedly committed a murder you
claimed you were innocent however your
lawyer did a shoddy job and you were
found guilty your sentence death by the
gallows it's the day of your execution
the crowd is boisterous for your death
the noose is placed around your neck a
bag over your head the executioner pulls
the lever and pause here's what will
determine whether you die quick and
painlessly or slow and excruciating the
drop height length of rope and placement
note the knot first the drop height the
height determined to drop the condemned
was a tricky one if the height was too
high you'd risk decapitating the
individual which didn't do well for PR
and if it was too short the hanging
would take too long which was also bad
for PR ideally when dropped from the
appropriate height the weight of the
body broke the neck but what would
happen if the height wasn't high enough
the force from the drop wouldn't be
strong enough to snap the vertebra
however it would be enough to crush
rupture and tear arteries in your neck
specifically your Cariah arteries which
supply blood to the brain tearing a
blood vessels results in internal
bleeding in the neck and because the
noose obstructs blood to drain downward
the face and neck would become engorged
as fluid so much that the eyes would
bulge and tongue stick out of the mouth
this is why the heads were often covered
to hide the grotesque process though the
individual would likely lose
consciousness within seconds from blood
loss they're alive to feel the acute for
and ruptured blood vessels from the drop
which would be extremely painful
next the Rope length the drop height may
be sufficient to cause the hangman's
fracture but if the rope length is too
long or too short the height won't
matter to long means you'll make contact
with the ground breaking your ankles
getting untied refit and dropped again
if it's too short it will lessen the
force place on the vertebra when dropped
and may not rupture blood vessels
meaning you'll die through strangulation
by compression of the airway
strangulation causes the face to turn
blue from lack of oxygen and produces
petechiae or small blood marks on the
face and eyes caused by bursting
capillaries death by strangulation
typically occurred after four to five
minutes however death wasn't official
until the heart stopped beating which
would continue minutes after death so it
was common to keep the person hanged for
up to an hour afterward finally the most
important variable in hanging the
placement of the noose if the noose is
placed in the right position even with a
moderate height you can guarantee an
instant death traditionally noose is
replaced in two positions with the knot
either under the ear called his
sub-aerial knot or behind the head and
called the occipital knot both of these
positions were inconsistent in causing
instant death and often caused
individual to die by strangulation or
sometimes decapitation surprisingly the
best position to place the knot was
under the chin known as the submental
knot this placement is the most
effective because at the end of the
draft that knot forces the individual's
head to hyperextend backward placing a
strong compressive force from the
hyperextension and weight of the body on
the vertebrae causing it to break the
same fatal injury happens when a
driver's chin hits the steering wheel in
a high-speed collision the impact
compresses the vertebrae thereby
fracturing it and snapping the spinal
cord in 1913 British anthropologist
Frederick Wood Jones published work on
his findings that indicated fatal
cervical fractures occur best with the
long drop and placement of the submental
nock which later became standard
practice in Britain so yeah there's the
science of the gallows not the most
humane way to die after all also since
it's late October and this is a
grotesque topic this technically counts
as a Halloween episode so here's a
pumpkin thanks for watching and have a
happy Halloween
you